on va faire une interview briseur de
ménage alors là on y est sophie est ce
que vous êtes toujours amoureuse de
pierre oui ouais vous dit sur un ton
banon mais celle ci apparaît surprenant
présent mais je crois que ça se
construit de plus en plus je vais pas
qu'il a un peu vieilli quand même mais
c'est pas mal ça lui donne un charme
supplémentaire
j'aime bien la pureté des charmes charme
les brides 1
les pantalons en cuir à son âge je
trouvais ça j'aime moyens - mais demain
ouvre très sexy en et c'est eux qui me
l'a fait acheter moi j'aime bien
m face et le total look en cuir c est ce
qui vous regarde toujours avec la même
fougue
non tu es ça dépend des jours non mais
ça dépend des périodes il ya des
périodes où il est plus ou moins
amoureux ces corps qui vous a dit je
t'aime pour la dernière fois en début de
semaine puisqu'il s'est fait un post it
chaque début de semaine tranquille vous
croyez que c'est pour vous qui reste
aussi coq est aussi ouais ouais c'est un
peu suspect quand même ça non non pour
moi puis c'est son boulot quand même ici
même date et des mois qu'il a intérêt à
faire attention
en tout cas ce que j'ai constaté c'est
qu'il maigri surtout lorsqu'il à une
émission de télé a présenté puisque pour
me dire moi c'est ça ça compte plus
quand même vous êtes d'accord avec sa
pierre mais seulement oui oui oui il va
gueuler dans la bagnole entre le
dernière fois que vous amenez un
week-end en amoureux c'est quand ça
existait déjà
je sais pas où on est c'est vrai qu'on
n'a jamais trop l'habitude de partir
tous les deux rémois n'ont fait plus
qu'un avec nos enfants
on a couru ensemble mais à chaque fois
on annule les week-ends en amoureux
pourquoi bientôt bon il vous ouvre la
portière de voiture oui
ouais ils vous donnent la main dans la
rue oui il vous faut encore du petit
déjeuner au lit
oui enfin au lit non mais il me prépare
mon p'tit déj tous les matins quand même
l'islam tous les matins moi je me lève
tôt à 6h30 il se lève avec vous à
s'éteindre une grossesse qui fait de la
télé toulon c'est comme ça c'est quand
elle a commencé son émission il ya sept
ans je suis dit pour t'aider je me
levais le matin de faire le petit
déjeuner je savais pas de cette durée 7
en série en cours
i ils vous regardent la télévision où
ils regardent le foot comme tout le
monde
un tu me regardes page c'est pareil je
relève le compteur de temps en temps ils
regardent les filles dans la rue alors
il est très folk est allé dire que c'est
le mec qui voit pas très bien et il n'a
jamais vu le super canon qui veut c'est
donc ce genre de là mais je me rends
compte qu'en fait il y voit très très
bien et ayant fait ses ses lentilles
fonctionne vous avais jamais pensé à
quitter ces faits n'ont pas sérieusement
nous a traversé l'esprit mais n'a non
seulement pour la saint valentin qui
fait quoi en général aux îles et il est
assez attentif quand même globalement
c'est quand c'est tout ouais ouais ouais
vous engueuler ah oui oui ah oui ah oui
dieu après à presse en général ce nom
s'engage duras ou et on s'engage on est
on est pas très souvent d'accord en fait
un don il faudrait arriver à se
convaincre maintenant ses choix
professionnels moi je suis pas toujours
d'accord avec ses choix et on discute
dur et quand je le gonflage il m'est
arrivé de me prendre un pot de peinture
jaune indélébile à l'huile sur la
tronche quand même ouais ouais on
exagère j'exagère de ville où les races
et je leur en ai tapé une belle couleur
une escale et ses chaussettes
ouais ouais ouais c'est ça que les
graves
gerald pour descendre la poubelle non
pas trop jeunes anciens sportifs la
manchette les clous comme franck par
tout ça c'est vraiment pénible
ouais moi j'adore l'ordre ça fait
combien de temps que tu n'as pas
arracher votre soutien gorge
exactement c'est la fin de la question
alors exactement
je crois qu'il n'est pas très bon il est
pas très doué pour des graphes et les
symboles ça dépend des soutifs il pense
que les préliminaires c'est important
avec la femme en tant qu ils portent vos
sous vêtements des fois ils auraient du
mal je pense
alors ça c'est une question bon mais
vous n'êtes pas obligé de répondre si
vous répondez pas pierre répondre à
toute façon c'est quand la dernière fois
que vous avez fait l'amour en dehors
d'un lit en dordogne en dehors d'un ami
pierre tu répondes bayer non je vous a
déjà proposé un plan à quatre avec les
castaldi flamands n'avaient ni eau ni un
plan à quatre noms non 1,3 pourquoi non
j'ai pas d'argent on a déjà parlé
ouais assurance est une nécessité sujet
sympa voilà exact on échange
voilà c'était bon exactement bien sûr
vous êtes jalouses de ses maîtresses
tant que je sais pas non mais il faut
rester vigilant à moi je reste vigilante
a déjà pensé à faire la grève du sexe
pour le faire chier ouais ouais
d'où l'utilité des maîtresses je verrai
une interview briseur de ménage est ce
que vous êtes toujours amoureuse de jean
michel
oui est ce qui vous regarde toujours
avec la même fougue clis dites moi il
fait le ménage à la maison jean michel
normand moi non plus hein et la cuisine
non moi non plus c'est quand la dernière
fois que vous emmenez week-end on envie
c'était aussi des eaux alors la dernière
fois qu'il vous a offert des fleurs
voilà je n'aime pas beaucoup les fleurs
et lui non plus il vous ouvre la
portière de la voiture
oui ils vous accompagnez les reports
quand vous partez je ne suis pas encore
parti
voilà vous avez pas vous séparer en fait
c'est pas s'il viendra vous chercher
quand vous reviendrez donc nous fait des
petits déjeuners augis du déjeuner au
lit j'aime face à dire regarde les
filles dans la rue
non il a une photo de vous dans son
portefeuille sur son portable
il laisse des messages d'amour sur le
miroir de salle de bain du rouge à
lèvres je t'aime je me lépine motors
c'était mon portable
c'est quoi qui vous énerve le plus chez
lui anne
c'est la drogue et c'est ma position et
ses chaussettes
on cherche la faille il est 10h donner
des miettes dans le lit mais je suis
très fouillée aussi bon mais on se
ressemblent beaucoup et ça me dérangera
pas enfin ouais vous l'avez déjà échappé
on travaille à bordeaux
non dans laquelle vous avez tourné
rajotte des corrections de ne rien rater
de l'ina l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus